recognize game let's roll
is it anyway hey oh it's hot 975 Ready
Set Radio live in studio my dude
Yelawolf yo mr. Rainey we're ready old
boys on had to anyway so uh wolf BAM is
finally coming out man a couple push
backs but it's finally here in November
15th right look at that red bird this
money first wait first okay that's my
bed I thought you were a real friend I
thought I was too until I got the date
wrong but I November 21 pushback couple
times I forgive you dog you know but uh
we had a couple things we wanted to
tighten up couple mixes and there was a
couple things visual we wanted to share
with people before the album came out it
was off for good reason man so November
21st is the official release date you
know thank you by the way for helping to
premiere the world premiere or let's
roll let's roll featuring Kid Rock shout
out to other audibles from Vegas who
produce that too yeah some of the
audibles is about to kid rock that's
what's that's what's amazing I want to
help mom the kid rock feature like I
mean you're you're a white dude from the
south I'm a white kid grew up in Arizona
like it rock was the man when I was you
know around you look as though he still
is the man what I'm saying like Kid Rock
is OG let me tell you something anyone
who kid he started when he started he
was open enough for two short opening up
for too short he went from that to
hosting the CMT's right that's crazy he
transcends all music Oh Ford's man are
you started opening you started hope as
opening act for too short now I went to
I went to Kid Rock's house with Marshall
on to pitch him to do this record yeah
man I was just blown away by like dudes
taste man I you know I've always said
since the beginning that you know whoa
at first with people how do how do we
make sense of your music what is it hot
in how's it work or yeah where do you
get it from with and layman's terms I've
always used kid rod all I said well if
we take a little Outkast little kid rock
nose with little beasties you know
yeah yeah cetera et cetera always
brought him into my list of inspirations
man and I was so right when I went and
met him I hey dude pulled up in Waylon
Jennings golf cart man a golf cart that
was painted like the General Lee oh wow
like that's how he came to the gate come
on you know what's he already a Depot
see already aware your music was he a
fan at all or um no actually he had he
had only heard of me through Marshall
and through a couple of his people but
he hadn't he wasn't familiar with the
music but we sat down and I played them
you know records on patron music and
there were certain phrases and lines
that really really caught his attention
which once you remember off top like the
line awful s roll the guy him was dipped
a mossy oak with a mullet Mohawk you
likey when he heard that mossy oak line
he was like okay mozzie oh god hahaha he
cracked a bottle of Jim Beam his own by
the way his own brand of Jimmy oh he's
got his own brand yeah he's got his own
line of Jim Beanz that's crazy faces on
the bar on the box that's nuts yeah
that's what's up man so anyway he's
great dude and ended up working out you
know that that he was able to get on the
island you guys down Marshall and Paul
when you got it when you got it back did
you cuz I like I mean I'm in radio and
you know I always I think I have a
pretty good year when it comes to hit
records and um you know it always just
everyone's always one hit record away I
guess from like the next level you know
what I'm saying no I mean and when I
heard the record up to me I think that's
the one you know that's a smash did you
feel the same way when you first got it
back well you were you like this is a
single well I knew that it was important
culturally you know and I never put too
much on any record yeah uh because you
know i I don't I don't know I like to
stay in the middle man I like setting
myself up for disappointment you know
yes I do believe in this record i do
believe this record is huge and i do
believe this record is going to do great
and change my life
um but you know at the end of the day
I'm very proud of it you know and I'm
proud of the accomplishment of getting
him on a record and doing the record
with him yeah it says a lot about how
far I've come as an artist it says a lot
about Alabama it says a lot about you
know shady records and the freedom that
I've been given to do the things that I
want to do and create the music that I
want to create so at the end of the day
man the goal is to make classics and to
put together the collabos that we put
together on this album had to make
perfect sense this record made perfect
sense to us I think it's amazing record
and you know at the end of the day they
don't matter the only thing that matters
is it Jem is it fun to listen to it is I
see it like like on some sports that are
highlights or something you're I mean
yeah you know let's roll you know
Crimson Tide the theme song maybe maybe
let's roll NASCAR yeah being so
impossible mess with man that's what we
get that I can't I can't hang with the
NASCAR well I'm gonna tell you the
Talladega and you you will be converted
okay I her desire that the experience is
fun nah the party three cigarettes it's
free everything that's what it's all
about yo so you just got off the tour a
hard white or like first time I met you
you were also ways yeah i was done two
runs with wisma and the first time I met
you yeah I was here at the house of
blues house of blues out yeah that was a
great show thank you for bringing me out
yeah real tough crazy died I became a
huge fan of you after that show I really
appreciate the you know you know yeah
well there's a few artists attic I feel
like I've been up on since book like I
think you and Freddie Gibbs or two
artists i guess i've been listening to
before everybody else that's what's up
man i sent you an email when your email
was a yellow wolf music @ yahoo.com or
something like when i was i was doing
radio in idaho its directive by the way
thanks Kevin I only heard the UH the
juelz hook you did I was crazy like
something I gotta hit this dude up but
um but yeah the tour man I mean it's a
headlining tour how was the reception
and you know just being out there and
you're the main attraction now well man
you know I've opened up for so many
people man right now and I've I've been
the opening supporting act happily for a
while you know and so to get back out as
the headliner especially revisiting the
cities that I've that you had already
been in it's a banana and opener it's
great man you know it's you know I my
fans I got to us I'll say this proudly
I'll take a thousand of my fans to 5000
of another artist fans um they're there
for a reason man that these fans that
come out to these shows are family right
you know and there's like our real
connection that they have with the music
with the attitude with the whole culture
of it all and the reception has been
great man every city was crazy every
city had a different energy um every
city had something else that they
brought as as a crowd as an audience um
a ton of sold-out shows an arbor was ann
arbor michigan was hands down the
craziest loudest craziest show on the
tour like I I could have just put the
mic at the edge of the stage and just
they put my yeah like loud though right
like really wrapped like I'm talking
about like I have verses that are pretty
choppy you know one off of all let's go
that i did with travis barker yeah yeah
and Little John Twista get lost ur moms
yeah and on it's a pretty quick verse
but they eat them as a crowd no no
that's every word like yeah it was crazy
like I don't know Michigan has the in
certain Bob and like it seems like
everybody could jam do you perform the
the the joint you did with tech nine in
the Midway
the all american choppers whatever is
called worldwide choppers sorry no I
don't that I still haven't learned that
verse entirely only because I haven't
put a real effort into trying to learn
the verse but um I probably will this
next run when i go to do my radioactive
tour i'm gonna do a lot of new records i
think i'm gonna add that one to the show
yeah be just that beat is dope is to
come in a lot of words to remember man
like no I can yo you know understand why
didn't you don't let my favorite rapper
of all times NAS but man he does not
remember his lyrics to save his life
ever seen it not he remembers about
sixty percent of everything and you know
cuz he'll just pull away from the mic
and come on son I know your Rhino your
lyrics better but it's I can imagine as
a rapper like especially if you have
such a you know such a long you know
someone like Nasser like yourself who
uses so many words be so hard to
remember everything well this might
sound like off kilter and um but it's so
relative to what we're talking about but
I sit and I watch this Willie Nelson
special the other night almost got quite
a catalog but his catalogue bigger than
anybody in the history of the world
insane yes so I'm sitting I'm watching
him perform and just like oh my that's
so that's so many lyrics there's so many
songs there's so many different melodies
smoked so much he's a stoner so he saw
like I was inspired by that like I
really i've been to shows where I've
seen teleprompters running for artists
and you know do a lot of the award shows
like that do what you gotta do but
teleprompters for their own lyrics well
and um I you know respectfully you know
you gotta do what you gotta do if you
can't remember it you got you know got
to pull it off somehow definitely but uh
I'm gonna really i'm going to try to
make a real effort man for the rest of
my career to really try to memorize all
this music cuz it's so easy to go in and
write a verse and just like the tec-9
record you know it's so easy going to
drop a verse put it out and then it's
like I cool next you know like you just
start you lose focus on that somebody
asks you to spit that virtually you're
right you're oh you know
my god it's not you know it's not cool
it's my own music I should be able to
recite it all everything that I've ever
wrote and um so that's this part of
growth man it's going to take time to
memorize all this music your writing
process um I mean if you're just driving
somewhere you're on a plane you think of
something you you know you are you kind
of like I know mmm is always referred to
you know he'll write a whole 16 on a
napkin or something this is that
something usually just right right to a
beat or um what if I feel inspired I
have to have something to put it down on
you know and like on the plane today
yeah you pull out some papers yeah i put
i got i wrote a verse literally over
over words and just over everything
there's no space on the paper really
it's actually like a some kind of flight
schedule that the flight attendants gate
but when it comes to come you know you
got to put it down on something i wrote
on this for anything in particular uh
this is just a verse I'm getting ready
for I'm going on tour with Wiz Khalifa
in a couple days in Europe oh ok and Don
I gotta make a stop at a at a station of
the DJ who gave me respectfully heads up
that he wanted to verse which I fully
respect that I like the fact that he
would give me the heads open up it was
she walking in and you're prepared I am
because if I walk in he's like spit a
verse an island got one now you're like
yeah and people like no that's you I
mean like they could cover it all they
won't but I was be like now I'm not
rapid so it doesn't affect me at all but
i would rather like you know i would
much rather coming in and I'm something
fresh you know and the cypher verse how
long did it take for you to write that
verse was it just man the cyber virus
didn't take me too long I was sent out
of beat and they said oh you know i
heard i just saw an interview did in New
Mexico he's like they switch the beat up
and use that [__] I'm keeping keeping
the same verse says I changed my change
in my box yeah I was so comfortable with
it and I was like well I'm not gonna
definitely not going to go there was
something I barely know and 16 bars and
we right before the cipher you know I
had made it clear they were asking how
many bars you got here I was like 16 on
this way they told me to spit 16 and
slaughterhouse and Marshall
okay that's what's up I'm so cool and
then M f'ers all had like 30 to 90 3 bar
versus um but I saw is I i I'm the
rookie it's cool it's cool there's
always next year next year cypher next
year cypher I'm spitting 198 bars he's
about to go the game on him in just one
do I like Busta Rhymes I hear me rap I'm
not sure not